翻訳: Shiho Nakamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さん 「デロリアン」という車を
ご存知でしょうか
映画『バック・トゥ・ザ・フューチャー』で
タイムマシンとして使われ
こんな風に扉が上に開くかっこいい車です
これが私の愛車です
実はこの車 EV —
電気自動車なんです
「デロリアン？ 電気自動車？ なんで？
売ってたの？」ということなんですけれど
実はそうじゃないんです
これ私達 自分達で作ったんです
これ 製造から36年くらい
経つ車なんですけれども
電気自動車ということなので
エコカー減税対象車なんです
なんか そんな面白いこともできちゃいました
私自身 この車と出会ったのが
やはり映画でした
未来や過去を飛び回る
かっこいいデロリアンに魅せられて
「ああ いいな この車に
いつか乗ってみたいな
できれば私も欲しいな」と
思ったこともあります
ただですね オリジナルのデロリアンは
ものすごく壊れやすくて
維持するのが大変なんですね
もともとそんなに
そこら辺にある車じゃないので
まあ夢だなと思って
それきり終わったんですけども —
通常この話はここで終わったりします
私 環境問題に興味がありまして
いろいろ調べているうちに
電気自動車という分野を
知ることになりました
電気自動車 CO2削減にとても有効な
手段だということが分かったんです
ガソリン車から電気自動車に
乗り換えるということですね
なるほど 環境問題に
そういう貢献の仕方があるんだと思った
それともう１つ EVって
実はとても構造が簡単で
壊れにくいという特長が
あることがわかりました
でそんな時にふと 気がついたというか
ひらめいたんです
デロリアンを電気自動車にしてしまえば
壊れないデロリアンができるじゃないかと
お これは面白い！と思ったんですね
さらに映画の中で ドクが自慢げに
タイムマシンを作った時に
言ったセリフを思い出しました
「どうせ作るんだったら
かっこいいほうがいいじゃないか！」
よし じゃあ 私もこのプロジェクトを
やってみようということで
たった一人で始めたんです
そしたらいろんな仲間が集まってきましてね
とても楽しい経験ができたなと思っています
で こちら 2015年10月21日
これが何の日か お分かりでしょうか
『バック・トゥ・ザ・フューチャーPART２』は
1989年の公開なんですけれども
その時にデロリアンが飛んで行った未来の年が
2015年10月21日だったんです
この日に飛んで行った デロリアンは実は
ここに置いてあるようにですね
ビールとバナナの皮で走ってました
それで 未来から飛んで来たというのが
描かれていたんですけれども —
これが未来ですね
私たちはその未来の日に
何か面白いことをやろうということで
ポケモンGOみたいなイベントを
ちょっとやったんです
友人にですね
Twitterに 位置情報を
自動配信するアプリを作ってもらいまして
それを持ってデロリアンで
広島市内をあちこち走り回るんです
そしたら「未来の日にデロリアンに会える」
ということで
なんかとても面白がってくれまして
いろんな人が
僕が今走っている所に集まってくれて
デロリアンを囲んで
「未来の日が来たね すごいね」
というのをワイワイやったんです
「今日ですよね 奴らが来たのが今日ですよね」
と言ってえらい張り切ったりとか
盛り上がったりする人がいたりとか
なんかとてもすごい 面白い経験ができました
その時にいろんな人が
こんなことを言うんです
「へぇ このデロリアンすごいですね
電気で走るんですか
でもこの車 生ごみで走ったら
もっとすごいのにね」って言うんです
電気で走るだけでも 結構大変だったのに
そこまで言うか
という気持ちがあったんですけど
じゃあ 実際に
やってみましょうかということで
実はこういう
『ごみで走る?! EVデロリアン』という
企画を実際にやってみて
みんなの前で走って見せました
生ごみを発酵させると
アンモニアとかメタンガスができます
そこから実は 水素が作れるんですね
その水素を使って発電したら
電気ができますね
それを充電すれば EVデロリアンというのは
もう電気自動車になってますから
なんと 生ごみのエネルギーで
走ることができるんです
しかもこれ ゼロエミッションなんです
どうです このむりくり感？
（笑）
ですけど やっぱりこれが未来に行き着く —
未来に向かうエネルギーのあり方という
意味では なんか合ってるかなと思います
広島大学の水素エネルギー研究者の先生方と
一緒に これをコラボしてやりまして
みんなの前で 水素エンジンで発電して
充電して「どうだ！」というのを見せました
水素エンジンというのは
出るのは排気ガスじゃなくて
水蒸気しか出ないので
全然臭くないんですね
「へえ 水素で動くエンジンってこんなんだ」
というのをみんなに見てもらったりして
みんなで未来の体験を一緒にした
ということになりました
私達の活動で 実は電気自動車というのは
とてもイノベーションの塊だ
ということがよく分かりました
さらにモーターとか電池とか
今 ものすごく技術が
どんどん進んでいるので
もしかしたら [積み]替えたら
性能がどんどんアップできるんです
この車もそうですが 実はこれまで
３回アップグレードしましたので
走行距離も
50キロから100キロにとかですね
急速充電器が使えるようになったとか
どんどん 出来たあとも
進化しているんですけれども
今 ここに映っている電池 —
これは今 大体120キロぐらい
走る電池なんですけど
電池がもっと良くなれば この車の状態で
300キロ 400キロ走ろうと思えば
できる時代が まもなく来る
ような感じがしています
そういうイノベーションをとても感じることが
できて なんか面白かったなと思っています
さて 2011年3月11日
この日に 何が起こったか
みなさん もちろんお分かりだと思います
東日本大震災、津波、原発のメルトダウン
過酷な放射線被害や故郷を追われる人たちの
理不尽さを目の当たりにして
エネルギーを真剣に考える日になりました
私も 考え方が変わりました
科学技術のあり方を 根本的に変えなくちゃ
いけないんじゃないか という思いです
やはり 大量生産 大量消費の
社会はもうダメです
そうではなく エネルギーもそうですね
豊かさの象徴なんです エネルギーというのは
それを足りないから 環境負荷を高めて
発電を増やすというのではなく
効率を上げる、まだ十分にうまく使えていない
再生可能エネルギーをうまく使う
そういった姿勢が
やっぱり求められていると思うんです
目標にしたいのは 世界一エコロジカルな
都市だった江戸だと思います
やはりそういう風な 持続可能な社会に向けて
私たちの暮らしをどんどん変えていかないと
いけないんじゃないかなという風に思います
実は その時ふっと浮かぶのが
デロリアンは最初
プルトニウムから走ってたんですけれど
それが これに変わりました
やっぱり プルトニウムから
バナナの皮へと進化したように
世の中がどんどん変わって
いけたらいいなと思っています
私 実はですね こんな壮大な夢を
持ってはいるんですけれども
その夢をどうやって実現していったらいいか
実はよく分からないんです
なぜかといいますと
ここで１つちょっと 白状しますけど
私 実はコテコテの文系なんです
形にするスキルって 持ってないんです
それを実現させてくれたのが
『デロリアンEV化計画』というブログでした
この場を使ってですね
活動の趣旨とか
「今こんなことやってる」
「でも ここで困ってる」
「 わかんないここ」 というのを
どんどん情報発信しながら
メンバー募集をしてました
そうしたら マツダのOBの方とか
電気配線の専門家、大学院生など
そういういろんなスキルのある人たちが
「面白そうだ」と集まってくれました
ネット上で 情報を
寄せてくれる人も出始めまして
わぁ これって … まぁ —
本当 そういう人たちと集まりながら
いろいろやっててですね
情報っていうのは 発信してる人のところに
集まるんだということがよく分かりました
この方は マツダOBの
昼田さんという方なんですけど
２年前に癌でお亡くなりになりました
とても物静かな 紳士だったんですけども
現役時代は 電気自動車の開発に
駆動系で関わってらっしゃいました
実際 その研究をしてる時にですね
これは面白いイノベーションだという風に
技術者としてお感じになったのですけども
実証実験で終わってしまって
とてもなんか やり残した感があったようです
のちに私のプロジェクトを知って
手伝ってくれるようになりました
２回目のアップグレードの時には
入院先の病院から来てくれた事もありまして
この仕事を最後の仕事という風に
思ってくれたようです
なんかとても
感謝の気持ちでいっぱいなんです
さらにさかのぼるとですね
ベース車の入手から
とても良いご縁がありました
私 このプロジェクトを始めるにあたって
ベース車は
捨てられそうなデロリアンがあったら
始めようという風に決めていました
２年間で 8000台しか
生産されなかった貴重な車なので
普通に走るデロリアンをわざわざ改造する
というのはやりたくなかったんです
そういう車はないかなと
ネットでいろいろ探していたら
東京の佐野さんという方が
事故に遭われて
全損で廃車になったデロリアンというのを
部品取り状態で売りに出されてたんですね
私は「 おお 出てきた！」
と思ってすぐ先方に連絡して
「これって簡単に直せない車ですよね？」
というのを散々聞いてたら
先方からこんなことを言われました
「他にもいろんな人から
問い合わせがあるんだけど
皆さん『この車ってどうやったら直せるのか？』
『直すのに幾らかかるのか』
という風に聞いてくるんだ
でも あなたって全く逆のこと聞いてくる
一体 何をやろうとしてんだ？」
で 私は
「デロリアンをEV化して
次世代に残せる車にしたいんだ」と
夢を 正直に話しました
そうしたら
「何だか面白そうなことやるんだね
よし分かった じゃあ この車
差し上げますからやってくださいよ」
ということで 私デロリアンを
タダでもらったんです
ただ 佐野さんが 実はCGクリエーターで
「ルーカスフィルム」という所でも
仕事をした経験がある方です
要は 同僚の中に
『バック・トゥ・ザ・フューチャー』の
スタッフもいた方から譲って頂きまして
なんだかそんな方から夢を託されたら
もう絶対やらないといけないよねということで
必死になってやりまして
そういった形で いろんな方との出会い
いろんな時間軸の中で
このプロジェクトを進めまして
何とかできました
車検を通した日が 2009年3月11日
ちょうど 震災の２年前だったんです
完成して以降 いろんな人が
「私もこんな事を考えていたんだ」という
言い方をしに来られる方がたくさんいました
でもプロジェクトが実際に形になる前は
とても否定的な意見を
言われる方が多かったですね
テスラCEOのイーロン・マスクさんが
こんな事を 実は言われていたのですけれども
「なんでテスラはそんなに早く電気自動車を
作れたんですか？」と聞かれた時に
「アイデアは思いつくよりも
実際に形にする方が
全然難しいだろ？」と
お答えしたそうです
私もやっぱりそうだと思います
アイデアって 考えただけでは
実は何もやってないのと
同じなんじゃないかという風に感じました
私の場合も じっくり考えて
まずできる所から形にしていきました
なので できる所からやったので
そのあとアップグレードもしたんですけれども
そうする事によって具体的になりますし
課題も見えてくるし
周りの人にも
「こんなことがやりたかったのね あなたは」
というのが分かってもらえる
そんな機会になったと思います
電気自動車をデロリアンでやって
よかったなと思うのは
見に来てくれた方が
とても未来を語ってくれるんです
それが大好きだったんです
普通の車で電気自動車を作ってみたとします
電気自動車に興味がある人は
来てくれるけれども
そうじゃない人とは
なかなか出会えないんですね
で もう１つ
とても性能の良いガソリン車がありますから
それとEVを並べると
走行距離が短いよねとか
そういったデメリットがすごく際立ちます
でも デロリアンの場合は
ライバルが プルトニウムか残飯です
そしてこの車を前にですね
まだまだ不十分だけど 未来につながる
ストーリーを提示してみると
皆さんが ものすごく楽しそうに
自由に未来を語ってくれます
この笑顔を見ていると
さあ次は何を始めようかっていう
気になってきます
それが 私の原動力です
そんな風に 10年間 デロリアンと一緒に
EVの世界を見続けてきました
これから先 どんな未来が
待っているのでしょうか
そしてどんな未来を作っていきましょうかね
未来って自分で作れると思うんです
皆さんとも ぜひ一緒に
作っていきたいなあと思ってます
ぜひ 一緒に作っていきましょう
それでは次は EVデロリアンが
空を飛べるようになった頃にお会いしましょう
どうもご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）